all right welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some usual rules
as usual
first please mute yourself during the
talk if you have immediate questions you
are welcome to unmute and ask but
otherwise please use the chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in the Q a session at the
end second today's seminar is open to
external audience so no classified
discussion is allowed finally the talk
will be record and upload to our YouTube
channel now let me introduce our speaker
it is an honor to host pension who is
the currently attendable track assistant
professor in the School of computational
Science and Engineering at Georgia Tech
previously he was a research scientist
at the Odin Institute for computational
engineering and Sciences at University
of Texas at Austin
before joining UT Austin he spent a year
at special and postdoc at eth storage in
2014-15
he obtained his PhD degree in
computational mathematics from dpfl in
2014. his research is driven by
challenging problems in scientific and
Engineering fields that involve
data-driven modeling learning and
optimization of complex systems under
uncertainty and focus on scientific
machine learning and certainly
qualification patient inference
experimental design and stochastic
optimization
today he will talk about derivative
informed neural operators please enjoy
the wonderful talk now without further
Ado let me hand it over to your pen by
asking a random question
yeah so if you could attend a lecture by
any scientist in the past or presence
who he or she be
well that's a very
good question I would say uh
well there apparently a lot of a
scientists that I like to learn from and
uh
one of uh you know the leading
scientists that would be uh Richard and
feminine a physicist and I learned a bit
more about their you know physical
background and uh you know the the sort
of like the first principle models that
uh you know we're proximating today with
uh to achieving involvement in New York
operators
yeah that would be definitely a good
choice but by many others as well so uh
thank you so uh please go ahead
um with your talk thank you Tony thank
you for your kind invitation and also
introduction so today I'm going to share
some of our recent work on a derivative
informed new operators it's a class of
New York operators and that are designed
into the U.S and essentially
optimization problems construct
constrainted by a large-scale partial
differential equations and also
um with many different applications as
Tony mentioned in basic inference
optimal experimental design and
stochastic optimizations this is joining
work with the gene will go at Georgia
Tech and with Professor Omar katas
jinton law Thomas only raspberry and
umbrella Baylor from UT Austin
so let me start with a few examples
um so first one is uh the radiation
inference of Antarctica ice sheet flow
so here you can see essentially the
install satellite observation of the
surface Ice Flow velocity
of the Antarctica ice and uh over the
years there is accelerated acid flow and
if all the lender are actually mounted
and got into the ocean and there is a
significant sea level rise so care about
this problem
um so the model itself can be described
by you know their their non-linear
viscose incompressible or fluid flow
essentially the stocks flow and
uncertainty of the problem
um depends on you know the vessel
sliding field essentially is a boundary
condition between the boundary
um a sort of like a land boundary of the
ice and land so we don't really know
about the vessel sliding field
I want to infer and distribute from the
observation data and in particular I
want to find the maximum a posterior
point of this parameter and here uh
there's a some reason to work on you
know finding this map Point by solving
an optimization problem essentially a
Newton best optimization problem
I can see here this is essentially their
map Point maximum a posterior point of
the parameter
um at the bottom boundary
apparently it is a random field it is a
random variable at each point and it's
infinite dimensional after the
discretization could be very high
dimensional
and the second example is a optimal
experimental design for tsunami 1e so
here you can see uh essentially how to
deploy a surface point and also a
tsunameter so once there is a earthquake
in the sea floor like the sea flow
motion you can quickly detect the
acoustic wave from the sonometer and the
surface point and you can pass it down
to their tsunami warning centers and
uncertainty of these problems comes from
you know the slip land earthquake fault
it's essentially their earthquake fought
due to this pressure high pressure the
generator there on tsunami it is a
depending on space and time so
essentially a space and time dependent
stochastic processes is also quite High
dimensional after discretination
and uh so the model can be described by
you know this elastic acoustic gravity
web equations and also once there's a
tsunami generated it follows this
shallow water equation so essentially a
tsunami is propagated to the coastal
city
very commanded by shallow water equation
and the optimization problem is
essentially I want to place the sensors
and there's a sonometer and the surface
boy in order to detect their earth crack
and also
um you know maximum uh tsunami warning
forecasting and uh so these sensors uh
actually placed to maximize the
information that it can gain from uh
um the sensors
all right so the third problem is about
stochastic optimization uh with
application for direct yourself
assembling material it is for instance
potentially can be applied in
semiconductor error so here what you can
see is the the die block a polymer so
you have two segments and have a
different like a foster track them to
form different patterns and uh so these
patterns can be formed by placing
certain guiding post on certain The
Psychotic item post or uh substrate so
that the materials can form into
um the pattern of morphology that you
want the model itself can be described
by either sort of consistent field
Theory or non-local uncannon Hill
equations that have been working on so
uh here's a one type of a targeted
morphology and we can place a certain
subtract for instance here complex a
substrate and it will attract the
material to form this targeted
morphology right and uh so the
optimization problem would be to
properly design the substrate or another
application the target morphology looks
like this one and then we can place our
guided post so essentially when we
decided their locations of the guidepost
such that the equilibrium state is
driven as close as possible to the
targeted morphology
however the problem is uh you know
there's a lot of uncertainty in this
system too there is a for instance
random initial phase of the materials
and the material properties and also
their uh temperatures of this process so
this uncertainty are also very high
dimensional and for instance here at a
given optimal design because of this
uncertainty the equilibrium can converge
to you you know different uh sort of
like State here you have a stat that you
want that is close to the Target
morphology but however there are some
other equilibriums and there are sort of
like a defects of the material you want
to minimize this kind of a defects by
stochastic optimization problem
so over this three different examples we
can formulate a few
um like abstract problems the first one
is the forward uncertainty propagation
so you have a complex system described
by a mathematical model R you have a
steady variable U here and uh now you
have an uncertain parameter represented
by Sita Sita as in other examples it
could be very high dimensional and have
a certain probability distribution and
they can propagate the uncertainty of
the parameter serve this system to some
quantity of interest for instance in
astronomy warning system You can predict
their water web height or you know the
magnitude and uh so uh there's
additional variable z z could be their
uh optimization variable experimental
design variable
so second problem is BS inference so
given some data which is typically noisy
the data actually uh you know a
collection of some observation of your
static variable U here and there you
have additive noise Epsilon follow
certain noise distribution so uh the
biggest inference problem is actually to
characterize the posterior distribution
of the parameter Theta which is a you
know proportional to the likelihood
function times the prior
and given the data you can effectively
reduce uncertainty of this parameter and
this reduce the parameter reduce the
uncertainty can also be propagated to
their quantity of Interest
but one of the problems could be like
how do you
um in the first place collect the data
right this is optimal experimental
design problem
so uh you can see here we have a
information again calligraphic U
represented by calligraphic U so we want
to maximize this information from our
experiment from our sensors and this is
z stands for the experimental design
variable and is average with respect to
the data or the data so essentially uh
we wanted like uh optimize our sensor
locations in order to collect the data
to reduce their answers as much as
possible as you can see after the
optimal experimental design you have a
reduced uncertainty for the parameter
and uh again you can propagate it to
their quantity of interest at this stage
with our calibrated model you can solve
the optimization problem so you have
some quantity of Interest it could be
like a control or design objective and
this still is a random variable you want
to compute some statistical measure or
risk measure and you want to minimize
this risk measure and there is
additional let's say penalization and
term or regularization term and this is
z here stands for optimal control or
design variable
all right so they're about like uh
there's four different problems we
consider and uh there are some common
challenges for these problems the first
is the model uh typically quite a
complex described by partial
differential equations have been
reviewing for this different examples
and they're expensive to solve and
uncertain parameters that they're high
dimensional and they could have like a
very complex distributions as
non-gaussian multimodal and locally for
his locally concentrated for instance
and then additionally for the
optimization problem including the
experimental variable their control
variable design variable those could
also be high dimensional and also
non-convex
to address this challenge that we
exploit the following opportunities the
first is that we can construct a certain
circuit models with the required
accuracy and also the several kind of
models can be evaluated very fast
and secondly so for the high dimensional
parameters and typically the from the
parameter to the solution or to the
observables in your inference problem or
to the objective in your control problem
those maps are typically intrinsically
low dimensional how to exploit the low
dimensionality would be one of the
opportunities and then for the
optimization problems uh typically for
high dimension but High dimensional
optimization problems we can use a
derivative best method or adaptive
optimization method this methods are
typically Dimension independent
all right so let me uh you know proceed
to this forward problem and essentially
the forward uncertainty provocation and
the many different kinds of uh you know
their uncertainty quantification problem
including the model reduction the
polynomial powers and recently their new
operators so when approximate the
solution operator essentially from the
Theta to the solution U or some quantity
of interest to map this quantity of
interest that could be a scalar a vector
or a function and a one approximated by
a neural networks F indexed by the
neural networks parameters w
and there have been several different
New York operators developed over the
last few years including their Fourier
New York operator uh which you know sort
of like transformed their input by
Fourier transformation and uh building
the neural networks in the frequency
domain and also there is a deep uh o net
depropriator Network
where the output is represented by a
sort of like a linear basis this basis
are constructed by so-called the trunk
net trunk neural network and the
parameter are mapped through the branch
net
um to the coefficient of this linear
basis and then there's a sequence of
development of reduced basis
architectures of the new operators
including their in the so-called deep
learning and reduce other models and the
PCA networks which essentially you apply
the principal component analysis for the
projection of the input and output map
and also recently I developed this
derivative form in the projected neural
network
and also there are a couple of
comparison papers on different new
operators including the following two
um one is a you know the comparison for
the Fourier new operator and deeper net
and another is a a comparison of
um including these two different new
operator and additionally there is a PCA
net and some other reduced basis
architectures so one of the conclusions
from this comparisons is a you know for
a larger scale and high dimensional
problems especially those problems
intrinsical low dimensionality this PCA
net and also there's a pod Depot net
essentially you perform some projection
of your input output to load Dimensions
those new operator tends to be
performing in the past from the
perspective cost and accuracy trade-off
I'm going to explain a bit more about
this point so the First Development we
had was under this so-called derivative
informed the projected neural network so
essentially instead of their PCA net
where you project their input parameter
Theta into a PCA basis or like a
calculate live expansion basis we
actually projected down to their active
Subspace which is a computed by forming
this Jacobin of this queue a transpose
and let's multiply this Jacobian text
average with respect to the distribution
of parameter Theta and then you compute
the eigenvalue decomposition to attack
the eigenvectors at the Subspace which
is a active Subspace for their you know
the output Q
and who projected their parameters into
this active Subspace and for the output
it would be their pod Subspace
essentially uh you collect uh snapshots
of the output and it performed the Pod
or SPD on it and you project it there
output to this basis and then after the
projection we have a neural network sort
of like leaving very low Dimensions low
dimensional input and low dimensional
output you can construct this neural
network with much a smaller number of
training data and uh this also
corresponds to the so-called encoder and
decoder but this encoder and decoder
actually constructed it more explicitly
using the projections and we have error
Bound for their input and projection
trailing by the trailing eigenvalues
essentially the projection error where
you from you have a you know the output
and the projection from the input and
output measured in our two sense that
can be upper bounded by their trailing
of the eigenvalues from the input and
output
if this eigenvalue is decayed pretty
fast then this error could be quite
small
so here's a uh one example a Hammer's
equation so essentially here uh we have
a parameter Theta on the velocity
and the acid is a gaussian random field
and we have a source term here and we
have observations of a
of this static variable along here the
surface
and uh so we have the input project the
input parameter Dimension is 16 000. and
uh by projection uh we can get it down
to let's say the dimension of eight a 16
or 32 depending on the decay of the
eigenvalues and here we have two
different neural network one is our deep
net and also another is without any
projection for this two different neural
networks we have a degree freedom for
the neural network as 2000 and also
about 24 million
so uh uh we have two different
projections uh as I said one is you know
the PCA or the koe company a lot of
expansion basis so this does not reflect
any their any of their you know the
solution Behavior but for the active
Subspace you can clearly see some web
patterns right and uh so here's uh the
accuracy of a neural neural network
approximation with increasing number of
training data and uh we have different
projections including active Subspace
projection the carry projection and also
we simply draw some random projection
bases and then we have the full space
neural network
so the Blue Line indicates the accuracy
by the active Subspace projection so
essentially you can see with a small
number of training data you already
arrive at a quite high high accuracy and
it's better than the other two
projections and it's better than the
full space and construction for the full
space because you have a lot of degree
Freedom you need a lot of training data
to arrive similar uh accuracy
okay so here's a sort of like a
scalability test because we have the
projection to the same dimensions it is
a independent of their input Dimension
let's say from the parameters Theta we
have either four thousand or sixteen
thousand and uh but for the Deep net by
projecting to the same dimensions we
have the same dimensions for their
neural network but the full space would
have a different degrees of freedom and
we have a similar
Behavior about the different projection
neural networks
okay so the second problem is about a
business inference
um
so here's a the abstract formulation of
the base inference why again is our data
observation data living in dimension as
as could also be quite high and see that
is our uncertain parameter we have the
front parameter to observable map f
f is the observation of your static
variable right so essentially uh this
Alpha depends on your static variables
and we have additive noise which is a
gaussian distributed with a covariance
gamma noise
and the previous row says that the
posterior distribution of this aceta
giving your data Y is actually given by
the likelihood times the prior
the logarithm you know the data are
conditioned on the Theta and then this
is normalized by this so-called model
evidence or normalization constant and
is actually the integral of the
likelihood function respect to the prior
distribution
but since the parameter Theta could be
very high dimensional and this model
evidence term is typically intractable
for computation and there have been
other many different kinds of methods
developed for solving based inference
problem including the LaPlace
approximation which is essentially you
build their gaussian approximation of a
posterior at the map point
and uh there is a mcmc sampling
techniques and also many of the variants
including
um using you know their derivative
information using Dimension reduction
and there is a sparse quadrature so to
compute this High dimensional integral
or some other high dimensional integral
respect to the posterior you can apply
the quadrature of based on sparse grid
and we'll have some recent work on that
and using hydrogen and best sort of like
a rescaling of the the dimensions and
the sparse quadrature and then there is
a whole class of different variational
inference using different transport maps
including polynomials radio basis
functions on neural networks
so um here with Fox on just to find the
maximum a posterior point which is used
in the LaPlace approximation so assume
we have a gaussian prior uh where we
have the mean Theta zero and also the
coverage gamma prior
and uh so the map point is actually
given by the solution of the
optimization problem where the first
term is a data Misfit it's a misfit
between the data and also your front
parameter to your observable map wedded
by the noise conference
so see here this is a the data y uh this
is essentially the satellite observation
of the flow velocity
uh and uh so the second term is a you
know sort of like a regularization term
or your prior knowledge this is the
difference between aceta and a mean
ready to buy the prior coverage
and by solving this uh optimization
problem you get a map Point maximum a
posterior point so here you can see and
this is a map Point turning from this
optimization problem and at this
midpoint you can evaluate your forward
map from the Theta to F and evaluated
the map point and this is actually uh
this is an evaluation which is quite
close to the data
um but to solve this optimization
problem you need to either use like
ready invest or new to investor methods
where you know this Jacobian of the
forward map is involved or the Hessian
is involved if you use a Newton best
method
and uh well in order to construct the
circuit for this from parameter to
observable map our new operator on
neural networks it should be accurate
not only for the map from the city to F
but also reliable for the Jacobian from
Cedar to the Jacobian of f
so here is our derivative informed
neural operator we have the same
projected neural network we have input a
projection to the Theta r as a
projection of our Theta by this inputted
projection basis of PSI and our neural
network is evaluated by you know this
neural network map in between and also
your times the spaces of the output
basis
so now
to trim this neural network we actually
include another term which is the
Jacobian because we want an accurate
Jacobian uh
in the approximation so the last
function essentially includes these two
terms one is the small neural network
for the low dimensional input output
here and also there you know the
projected output
and then the second term is the Jacobian
it's a Jacobian of the neural network
respect to the input which is a the low
dimensional input right and uh so you
can compute the Jacobian and then also
project it from the left and right to
the low Dimensions now instead of like a
million by million Dimensions you have a
let's say 10 by 10 Dimensions depending
on your number of projection bases
so how does it perform let's see uh for
a particular inverse problem with the
density flow which is quite simple we
have observation points here and this is
our true State variable and follows a
elliptic problem which is a log normal
diffusion problem with where the Sita is
gaussian distributed with covariance
given as a this elliptic operator the
fraction of the elliptic operator which
is corresponding to the Martin
covariance where I have a Dera and the
gamma that was a positive
parameters that can control the
correlation and also variance of their
random field and also you have a
laplacian term
so um now to compute the map point but
we can replace our forward map
the F by our neural network
approximation right this is our
approximation of the dyno and uh so we
can actually solve the optimization
problem in load dimensions in their
input projected coefficient Dimension a
coefficient space for instance here
instead of the original High Dimensions
it is simply an aceta R which is a
projected Dimension let's say instead of
millions it is a 10 and it can solve
this optimization problem image a low
dimensional space and you can replace
the original forward map by the new
operator so here are the results
let's look at the right first so we have
the three different quantities that are
approximated including their forward map
itself and on the right is without the
Jacobian training it's simply like just
training for the effort itself without
the Jacobian and you can see there is a
decay of the error with increase in
number of training samples this is a
relative error and also you can observe
the sample that reduce the Jacobian so
here you can see uh we have the reduced
the Jacobian we want to approximate this
reduced the Jacobian and this is the
decay of the reduced the Jacobian in red
and then in a green there is a the map
Point
um so this is a map that we approximated
by solving the optimization problem
using the dyno using their neural
network without their Jacobian training
but on the left we actually included the
Jacobian training we conserve not only
the map itself F here and also the
reduced the Jacobian they're more
accurate then if we do not include the
Jacobian information but more
importantly for the map point it is much
more accurate than this main point about
it when order magnitude Improvement
so uh yeah this is a you know using
their Dyno to find the map point and buy
the optimization and here so we have a
measure size of 64 by 64 and also tested
for 128 by 128 it can observe some other
Behavior
and the neural network size is the same
because the projection Dimension is the
same again
and uh
all right so now let me come to the
third
example which is the optimal
experimental design problem
uh so here is in particular for the
optimal sensor placement
uh for instance here for the placement
of the tonometer and strategically and
uh the problem can be formulated as to
place a certain number of sensors out of
a d candidate sensor locations you could
have like a really large number of a
candidate sensor locations and you want
to select only a small number R number
out of it so the observable map f is
given by the so-called design Matrix
times uh the observation at all the
candidate sensor locations so design
metric itself is a matrix of R by D
and as you can see here we have nine
candidate sensor locations if we
selected the first the sensor at the
third place where we have the first row
at the third third column is one and uh
you know if the second one second sensor
is picked at the fifth Point well then
the second row has a fifth column one or
the other is a zero so essentially this
design metric is a binary
as uh in fact Napoleon and his tax value
of zero and a one the sum of all the
rows is one and the sum of all the
columns uh sorry some of all the columns
is one some of the other rows is a
number between zero and one in fact it
is either zero or one so you need to
solve our condition problem with respect
to this design Matrix and here's a one
particular formulation which is best
under variance so the variance best
optimal experimental design where we
have the optimality from their you know
statistic Community the a optimality or
D optimality the optimality is defined
as the chest of the posterior covariance
and suppose you have a LaPlace
approximation which is you know the
posterior covariance evaluated at the
map point
and you take the chance of it the trust
essentially measures
um
how uncertain it is right how much
uncertainty you have you want to reduce
this uncertainty by Design This W so
essentially you want to minimize respect
to this w
but this stress actually depends on
um you know the realization of your data
Y and also your design and W so
essentially both the map point and also
the covariance will depend on this Y and
W so you take take the average with
respect to this Y and this is Theta
and the de-optimality is the determinant
of this covenants instead of the chest
now the posterior covarence
um under the gaussian assumption it is
given by this term so you have the
Hessian of the misfit term and you have
a you know the hedging of their prior
regulation term which is simply their
covenants of the prior inverse and this
will be the Hessian term so the Hessian
term involved with the second order
derivative you can actually approximate
it by the Gauss Newton Haitian and here
you only care about the first order
sensitivity information you have the
Jacobian evaluated the map point and
here is the Jacobian transpose this is
Jacobian and the noise covariance so
essentially you need to compute and this
map point and also this Jacobian
repeatedly again again for a given data
Y and also the design W apparently this
is a quite a challenging for large-scale
PD constrainted optimal experimental
design problem
and uh so here more recently we
developed this new the so-called
derivative informed Jacobian neural
operator well the reason is because our
Dino is derivative informed the neural
operator
um Can compute the map Point pretty well
as we showed before but however for the
full Jacobian uh the approximation error
is actually quite large I'll reduce the
Jacobian that we measured is relatively
small but for the computation of the
future copy which is needed here the
approximation is actually quite a bad so
we developed this Jacobian neural
operator where we perform a Jacobian
projection first of all a projective
Jacobian projection
um onto the Subspace formed by the
active Subspace and then we have a
reduced the Jacobian we vectorize it
again for many different snapshots at
different locations and we perform
another SPD on it
so essentially another projection and we
can get a relatively small
uh dimensional quantity now we compute a
neural network to approximate the
Jacobian and then we can reconstruct
this Jacobian
and for this one we call this Jacobian
neural operator
and in fact uh you would wonder you know
here you have a a parameter that can
project into different subspets right
either PCA Subspace and also active
Subspace and in fact for the computation
of the map point and also there you know
the Jacobian the the stress and
determinant we need to use a different
projection basis for the input and
here's evidence
so on the left uh we can observe you
know this is a the Reconstruction of the
map point you compute the map point and
you project this map Point into
different bases either active Subspace
or their PCS Subspace as you can observe
here if we project it down to the PCS
Subspace with increasing number of bases
you get a smaller and smaller error but
if you project down to their active
Subspace uh the error Still Remains
quite large
and uh what the reasons because the map
point is actually is found not only
respect to the data but also there is a
regular regularization term this piece
of air bases are actually their eigen
basis of the prior conference
and for the Jacobian itself you need to
project it down to the active Subspace
in order to get a small approximation
error of the Jacobian or reconstruction
error for their Jacobian and because
this Jacobian depends sensitively on the
first order information right
okay so we applied this
um Jacobi near operator uh for the
evaluation of the address and also
determinant on the left it is a chest
you have a defined element to address
estimation essentially we don't use a
surrogator here we take it as the truth
and we have a neural network address
estimation and I can see it is a very
highly correlated and we have error uh
the mean of the error is about less than
one percent standard deviations of 1.2
percent and for the approximation of the
determinant is about a two point uh two
point is for three percent also with a
standard deviation 2.55 essentially
they're very highly correlated so you
can trust your new operator to select
your sensors
okay now let me come to the last one of
a stochastic optimization problem
and uh so uh as I mentioned before this
stochastic optimization problem can be
formulated as you want to minimize a
certain control or design uh Z in a
certain atomizable set
and you have a sort of like a risk
measure or statistical measure of your
objective function Q
and then you have a certain penalization
term
here we consider a special
um risk measure which is a so-called
conditional value at risk
so let me give you an example here
here's the density of your Q right this
is a one-dimensional Q and uh so here's
a value at risk for a given parameter
beta
the beta is sort of sort of like the you
know better quantile here is the
probability
um this error is the probability and
this one is the quantile which we call
this value at risk the conditional value
at risk essentially
um the average or the integral of this
quantity of Interest by the quantity of
Interest larger than this quantile so
essentially you take the average of this
Q respect to the probability and density
here
the conditional value at risk provide a
more conservative risk measure
and uh in fact it is often used in you
know their financial engineering risk
management is also called expected a
shorter for the loss it varies between
four different and better if it better
equals to zero and then essentially
you can you know use the risk neutral
approximation risk neutral minimization
and if a battery equals to one
essentially care about either extreme
cash which is a worse scenario of
optimization
and uh this is sivar can be reformulated
as a uh you know as a minimization
problem
I respect a certain real number T and
then you have a here as Q minus t you
take the positive part is thresholded
for the positive part and since this is
a stretch holding is non-continuous it's
non-uh differentiable
uh so uh oh sorry so it's not it's not
smooth if we want to apply any let's say
grading or Hessian best optimization
method
um we want to do some smooth
approximation as exploited in this
recent paper
okay so uh for this uh ouu problem I
call it like optimization under
uncertainty ouu problem
uh we developed this so-called
multi-input reduce basis uh derivative
we formed a new operator
so the reduced basis is quite clear we
use the reduced basis for input output
projection the body input is essentially
you know we have a the input of the
parameter Theta and we did the
projection of the parameter into low
Dimensions we also have an optimization
variable so we have multi input right so
typically uh here we can consider either
High dimensional optimization variable
or load dimensions and in particular for
this work we consider parametric
optimization variables instead of
function valued optimization variables
so it becomes a relatively uh moderated
dimensions and uh so now we use the same
pod projection for the output we build a
neural network in between
and then we also train our neural
network by including the Jacobian
respect to the optimization variable
instead of respect to the parameter now
so because we need to solve the
optimization I respect the optimization
variable
and z
all right so now our data generation and
training are both scalable in the sense
uh in our loss function as I briefly
mentioned it before we project
everything down into the low dimensional
Subspace including their function itself
and also the Jacobian
and uh so now the quantity here in the
loss function is actually quite small
dimensional
but one particular point is that you
have to compute this Jacobian right the
Jacobian of U respect to Z you have to
generate the data it would wander uh
could it be quite expensive but in fact
it is not uh we can solve it very
efficiently by exploring the Joint Base
measured so essentially here the
Jacobian data generation attacks only
this number of additional linearized PDS
of and this number you know the
projected dimension for the output and
also the dimension for Z
and uh so this Jacobian projected into
their output Dimension is given by this
one by Chain row if tech the Jacobian
and you would have a you know this um
Jacobian of the operator PD operator
respect the static variable and this is
a Jacobian respect to Z
so for this problem uh essentially you
have to solve because this is this
becomes a linearized the PD operator at
a given View
even if it is the PD uh itself it is
non-linear so you can solve this
um sort of like a linearize the PD
operator depending on their size of Ru
and DZ you can solve either here as a
sort of like a linearized forward
problem or linearize the joining problem
and then again so you have to solve it
for you know perhaps like a 10 or 100
times depending on this Dimension right
but in fact here this is the same
linearized operator you can just
factorize it once and reuse it as a
directory solver of preconditioner so
here are there are two examples let me
let me focus on the 2D navigation to
solve the static PD you have about 13
seconds
but if a one rule Factor radiation is
only three seconds and after you
factorize it a subsequent I'll use solve
for this Jacobian generation texture a
small fraction of the time
so here's a cost accuracy comparison for
the ouu problem and uh
on the left we counted there a
computational cost in terms of how many
pde solves we need so we have either the
newer operator as a surrogate or we can
solve the PD directly right as a
reference so in the offline we can
generate the data the solution the
Jacobian for the neural Operator by
solving a certain number of pdes and in
offline we don't have to solve nnpd if
we use a PD best ouu measured and in the
online we don't have to solve any pde
for their new operator basis surrogate
and about for the pde the case we need
to use some sample average approximation
to compute their risk measure or the c
bar for instance and then we need to
solve a lot of PDs each of the
optimization step and for the accuracy
it's essentially for the approximation
of the c bar there is a apparently
biased from this surrogate right but the
variance can be very small because you
can afford to use a lot of samples to
evaluate this c bar
but for the pdecas there is no bias but
there is a sampling error you can only
afford it to solve for so many PDS to
evaluate the c bar so there is a sort of
like this buys and various thread off
so here for solving this ouu problem uh
we can use either you know the circuit
and the new operator or the PD and we
can measure the total cost by the number
of data pde solves
and the steady PD solves are used for
you know the training data generation
for the new operator and also uh you
have to solve it if you use the PD best
optimization
and then we can solve the problem uh we
can compute some reference solution or
reference to choose a solution which is
to solve all the pde best optimization
problem with a sample size in the sample
average approximation pretty high to a
thousand and then now we can compare the
C VAR essentially at Optimum controls
and I can measure the relative error
against the reference this is what we're
going to do uh to measure the cost and
accuracy trade-off so here's example
which is a flow control around a bluff
body we have a uncertain input velocity
field it is a gaussian random field we
assume that is it only in One Direction
in their X Direction and as a causal
random field is a Martin covarence and
we have a control variable along this
two body which are parametriced by B
splines this Phi of a z is a control
variable uh and the Z is a parametric
control variable
now I have two different objective
function once the first cause of
dissipation objective function which is
a you know attack the uh sort of like a
symmetric version this is a the tensor
product detect the integral of it
and another is a tracking type objective
function you want to minimize the
difference between your U velocity and
also targeted velocity
we have a penalization on the velocity
on the control velocity here with the
penalization parameter offer
so here's our discretization we use a
non-uniform mesh and uh which is Taylor
hood and find the element we use the
color can release a square stabilization
for to stabilize the problem and with
weekly imposed boundary condition for
the duration lab Android condition
and also we use a viscosity continuation
to solve the problem
so here is a full dimension of the
stator variables 42 000 and the reduced
the dimensions about 200 and the
parameter along the boundary is very
small is about 101 and it was due to the
you know projection to this 100
and the control is 18 Dimension or it's
parametric so now the four neural
network architecture is actually quite
small the combined input is 118
Dimension the output is 200 Dimension we
use hidden layer uh the dimensions at
400 two hidden layers
and here's a result we have minimized
viscous anticipation without the control
here and you can see their viscous
dissipation is effectively minimized by
solving this problem
uh well let's take a look at it there
you know the cost accuracy comparison or
trade-off so here we present three
different solvers one is that the PD
software in Black we didn't use any
surrogate but we use like a certain
number of a sample average approximation
samples in order to compute the c bar
and this is an increasing number of
samples to compute the c bar and this is
a total number of PDA solves along other
optimization steps and this is a
relative optimal cost error we can see
with increasing number of sample average
approximation samples uh you can have a
smaller error error for the optimal cost
and then here we have another two
different circuit one is it without the
Jacobian training and when the wizard
Jacobian training so here these numbers
indicate their number of training
samples for instance here we use 256
training samples we can achieve about
this error that is a comparable to uh
here
uh the PD uh solve using this number of
uh PD solves so essentially there is
about one order of magnitude reduction
of total number of PD softs including
other offline data generation
for the historical models and apparently
this Jacobian training this Dyno is much
better than their uh neural operator
without Jacobin and here's a viscose
dissipation and here's a tracking type
for the tracking type as even more
evident is essentially with about a 256
training samples it achieved the error
and that cannot be achieved by the PD is
of even up to this number of total PDS
of about two orders magnitude more PD
solves you can you still cannot achieve
the same accuracy
so essentially our Mr Dino achieves
about like about 100 or one and two uh
10 to a 100 More Sample efficiency
compared to if just some of the PDS
all right so here is an interesting
comparison
um
so here on the left we just compare the
accuracy for the solution in R2 error
right so with the with the Jacobian
training about the 256 samples we about
we arrived about 202 percent of error
which is larger than if you do not use
the coping 20 and uh but however for the
ouu problem if we measure the optimal
cost and is actually smaller than if we
do not use the coping training so
essentially this Jacobian training does
not only help to improve accuracy for
the solution but more importantly it
include increase their accuracy for the
ouu solution
all right so here's a few other uh
computational costs uh so for their 2D
Navy stocks equation after you construct
it when evaluation it takes about this
second and it can actually evaluate it
batch wise as we did uh so about a 2000
samples uh you can evaluate them
together it only takes about a 0.3
seconds
and uh so essentially there is a
acceleration about a hundred thousand uh
times compared to the PD solve um and uh
so here is a total cost a breakdown of
the total cost let's look again for the
Navy stocks if we just generate the data
of the solution without Jacobian this is
the time about a 13
000 seconds to generate the data
if you include the Jacobin data
generation it's only an incremental cost
it's about a 25 more cost of 16 000.
so essentially all the costs are
actually spent on the data generation
the pre-processing for you know the
projection and also on the neural
network of training actually very cheap
because we do everything in the reduce
the space
all right so here's a test test for 3D
Navy stocks flow control problem
uh again we have uh this is a similar
setup but it's in 3D now the standard
Dimension is one Milli the reduced the
dimension we still use 200 and the
parameter along the boundary now is 2D
class is a four thousand and it reduced
Dimensions 100 again the control and
dimension is about 50. so each of the
forward is solved for this non-linear 3D
navigation it takes about 30 minutes
using 48 CPU cores
and uh we generate about a 448 samples
for the training and after the training
we can achieve about 1.5 of the error
for the approximation of the solution
and then each of the neural network
evaluation uh is about like 10 million
times faster than the PD soft
and more importantly we can solve the
ouu problem Optimum control problem
subject to this uncertainty very
efficiently and here we have an
uncontrolled cast for the viscose
dissipation
and here after their optimization you
have a reduced viscous dissipation and
we solve this problem after the
construction of a newer operator we
solve this whole problem under one
minute
and if you think about the one PD solve
already 30 seconds 30 minutes and this
is a
a very efficient
okay let me come to my conclusion uh so
we developed this derivative informed
new operators and all uh and several of
us different variants and as a sort of
like the Merit of the accurate
approximation for their input to Output
the map right the map of the solutions
of the map of there from the parameter
uh the observation optimization variable
to their
objective function to the observables so
by using the dyno this approximation
becomes more accurate compared to
without using the Jacobian training and
more importantly for the Jacobian solve
it becomes very useful in the
optimization problem and becomes more
accurate
and we use the reduced basis
architectures and then we make the
training in the reduced space so and
this training becomes a scalable it's
independent of the nominal dimension of
the input and output space
and only um and also we showed that uh
for this Dyno it only requires a small
number of training data for our tester
cases compared to without using the
Jacobian and uh and also it is very
powerful for all these different
optimization problems including you know
finding the main point in the inference
optimal experimental design and Optimum
control problems on a certainty
um so this work is sponsored by uh NSF a
doe and DOD and you can find
um you know pretty much the results in
this slides and there's four different
papers
thank you very much for your attention
yeah thanks thank you for the wonderful
talk thing
um yeah I find it very interesting I
think um our audience too as well so
let's go to the Q a section
um
yeah now right now we have we don't have
any questions yet if the audience have a
question please like use the raised hand
or
um feel free to amuse yourself but maybe
I can kick off with a question so I I
myself find the directive training very
I mean crucial and important question to
think about in Practical applications
using all these non-linear structures
and I'm curious about the details of the
Jacobian compression using the basis
that you show very in the very beginning
so in my experience this derivatives
um can be much harder to compress than
the state variables so that's it yeah to
your problems
uh yeah this is actually a quite a good
point because typically uh for the
compression of uh you know this F this
map itself uh it is uh uh much more
let's say like a uh it's much easier
than the compression of the Jacobian and
uh in our test case uh this jacobians
also is quite hard to compress that's
why we applied this a two layer sort of
like a compression firstly we apply this
uh input projection using this active
Subspace evidence to buy here and the
active Subspace is actually quite
crucial if we're not and then you see
this reconstruction error is actually
quite big if you just use a PCA
and the secondary we do another layer of
a compression by vectorizing the Jacobi
Matrix as a vector and we perform
another SVD on it so this is a a
compression uh so sort of like a two
layer compression from very high
Dimensions it's a matrix to a small
dimensional coefficient vector
I see yeah that sounds very smart idea
too like circumference those issues
maybe I can take advantage of your smart
idea next time when I um have to like do
some compression to the derivatives
yeah sure talk more about it yeah sure
uh so John has a question so um he asked
when constructing a surrogates do you
always sample the observation points
uniformly
uh yeah that's another a very good
question so
um in our projection construction we
actually we sampled pretty much all
uniformly we we draw the samples from
let's say here uh here for the
construction here we draw the samples
according to their distribution let's
say for the parameter Theta is a
gaussian distributed we draw samples
from the gaussian distribution but this
is a not necessarily the most efficient
sampling for instance uh in our last
case of a stochastic optimization uh and
if we want to sample more meaningful or
helpful samples for the c bar right we
will draw samples from here instead of a
lot of samples here and uh but we
haven't explored this idea yet
okay
and store answer so I I don't see
another question so maybe I can ask one
more uh about the uh the very last
application that you talk about the yeah
the oh you like yeah the optimization
under uncertainty I see like yeah this
is a fantastic example I like uh I
learned a lot but so the model problem
here is still like
um like a static
um I mean time independent case so do
you see like this
um I mean this approach can be extended
to like time dependent problems and what
will be the difficulties there yeah this
is an excellent question uh in fact uh
for this different cases that I showed
uh they're all uh studies that depends
on their you know neural operator
approximation from their input function
to Output function we're currently
working on a Time dependent problems
um of course there's a first of all uh
our framework it depends on the you know
reduce basis architecture in time
dependent problems especially for like
for instance web propagation this is an
unnecessarily a low dimensional uh we
can perform perhaps some other like
encoder decoder with non-linear
Dimension reduction and secondly we need
to adjust our new operator uh to also
take into account at that time input for
instance there are a few different uh
approaches uh using like either a Depo
net where you have the time in the chunk
net or you have like the newer PD or
newer OD type of approach and uh there
are also some other different approaches
that we've been exploring
I see yeah thanks for the answer like
yeah I find all the applications very
interesting and yeah I I I think many uh
audience in the lab will be interested
in like knowing more about your work so
thanks for giving us the talk